dr henderson  dr kirby so sorry i'm late  good to see you again uh we met  briefly while we didn't meet but i was  in the room when you came to our office  a little while back  michelle shugert a little while back  that was months  it was uh yarborough park in the car  just me today  i get it you're disappointed uh  absolutely not  when you say just you today do you mean  just today today  every day hereafter you're our lead  like i said i get it you're disappointed  i'm probably a little too young maybe a  little too woman for your liking  neither is true guard please thank you  but what i can tell you is that i am  passionate about this case well really  every case but especially this one and  people tell me that i'm good at my job  even though it makes me exceedingly  uncomfortable to  say so  you